in some conflicts there is a clear good
guy and a clear bad guy say America
versus the dirty rotten Godless commie
Soviet Union in the Cold War
in other cases maybe a little more of a
complicated conflict there is at least a
clear Ally involved let's say the United
Kingdom versus Argentina in the
Falklands War
but in some conflicts say the iran-iraq
war for example you don't really like
either side and you mostly wish that
they could both lose it was this last
sort of conflict that just played out on
the streets of Portland where a white
leftist woman and a vaguely ethnic
leftist man yelled at each other in the
middle of the street
s
we're [ __ ] kind and we make space
okay and as someone who's from here as
well I'm so tired of people driving like
you just did all right get on my face
[Music]
we are in support
[Music]
you white lady
I I love it I love it I can't look away
like a car accident which there may have
been a car accident here eventually
there might have been I can't look away
I love how she screams it's not about
race
um
sure seems like it's about race for that
guy and it's about race because the libs
for decades have cultivated and promoted
a decidedly racial ideology that says
white people are evil and every other
type of person is good and everything
that is in even the slightest way
European must be disparaged and
overthrown because Western Civilization
is evil and now that ideology is coming
back for the libs for those white Libs
with a vengeance I myself
I happen to be immune to white guilt
perhaps this is because I am Sicilian we
are the swarthiest of the arguably white
people uh something about the extra
melanin I think inoculates us to white
guilt perhaps but I do not hate myself
and I don't hate my ancestors and I
don't hate white people or any other
group of people because of their race
and I don't hate Western Civilization
I actually like my neighbors and my
ancestors and my country and my
civilization and I want to build all
those things up and I want for them to
succeed
there's a big difference between the
right and the left today the
conservatives welcome everybody they
encourage everybody
any race any sex whatever
we encourage everybody to come on in if
they want to support our cause we are
constantly trying to win people over
we're always bragging about winning over
the old school liberals the old school
Liberals are coming over to us the
Hispanic vote is coming over a larger
percentage of the black vote we're going
to get it the libs on the other hand are
not only not welcoming new people
they are actively excluding their own
supporters if they happen to be of the
wrong race or sex
they're telling white people including
white liberals to shut up telling men
including liberal men to shut up
they're telling women including liberal
women who oppose transgenderism to shut
up
they are eating their own they're going
after Bette Midler now for goodness
sakes they are devouring their own and
they have to devour their own because
their political program is to devour
it's to break everything down
topple every statue the revolution
always eats its own children I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Alex Benson
who says as someone who is mauled by a
bear in the woods when I was 15. I have
to say Michael that you're bare phobia
is completely understandable I share it
with you wow I'm sorry to hear that
happen to you you obviously have
firsthand knowledge though of my deeply
irrational fear sometimes fears can be
rational and sometimes it's probably
even more common when conservatives
disapprove of something
it's not from fear we just we just don't
like it and we think it's bad for
everybody involved not everything has to
be a fear not everything has to be
irrational when people who believe that
men
are actually women are lecturing us on
our irrational thoughts and clearly
something's gone a little red it's a
little pot and Kettle type of situation
I think we've got to protect our minds
our communities our country when you
want to protect your home you got to
check out ring right now head on over to
ring.com
Knowles the summer is upon us it is time
for people to travel I think about half
my team is out right now they're all out
sick probably sitting on a beach sipping
a pina colada somewhere it's why you
need to have a ring you want to make
sure that your home is protected whether
you're in the home or whether you're
outside the home and you're on a beach
on the other side of the world ring
protects not just your front step you
know about Rings video doorbell ring
protects not just your windows and your
doors from freeze fire flood the bad
guys but if you get ring alarm Pro if
you become a pro just like me GoPro you
can protect your physical and your
digital home CNET calls ring alarm throw
a giant leap for home security I love
these guys I totally I trust these guys
they've been with this show since the
very beginning head on over to ring.com
Knowles right now that is ring.com do
not wait protect your home make sure you
can rest easy this summer protect your
physical and your Digital Life ring.com
Knowles
the revolution is eating its own the
libs are pitting everyone against each
other the white libs are now going after
they're they're yelling go back to where
you come from to the Native American
Libs in whom they have cultivated this
sense of identity politics within the
Native American lives are calling the
white Libs colonizers you've got the
feminist Libs they're not so happy with
the transgender Libs but the transgender
lives they say the feminist lives are
turfs they're a phobic they're awful
they're everybody is at each other's
throats
it kind of it reminds me of C.S Lewis it
reminds me of screw tape letters where
the the screw tape letters is this uh
book uh this imagined a series of
correspondence from a demon to his
nephew demon and they talk about how
they're going to win over souls and and
ruin Souls among human beings and the
thing you quickly learn about the demons
is they all just want to eat each other
they don't love each other like in the
good sense of Love meaning willing the
good of the other person they just want
to consume and devour each other it's
kind of that way with the libs they're
just they're just devouring each other
right now you're seeing this with the
singer Macy Gray Macy Gray is a huge lib
Macy Gray is such a big lib that she
campaigned a few years ago to get rid of
the American flag she said the American
flag no longer represents America that's
a terrible image it's basically just the
new Confederate flag and she was going
after the January 6th there is and she
was attacking half the country she is a
big time bona fide card-carrying lib and
and Macy Gray just went on Piers
Morgan's show and said hey guys you know
man I'm a big live and everything but
um
transgenderism is it's kind of crazy
right
and I I will say this and everybody's
gonna hate me but as a woman just
because you go change your plots doesn't
make you a woman right sorry
you feel that I know that for a fact
she's right she's right stop the clock
twice a day she's right she knows it for
a fact
just because you go in and mutilate your
body that if you're a man that that's
not going to make you a woman and she
says this and she gets a whole lot of
backlash JK Rowling is another very
liberal woman who has made this point
and now she is Public Enemy Number One
for the intersectional libs they call
her a Turf a trans exclusionary radical
feminist they're just they're just
hemorrhaging people from their Coalition
on the left well if you don't agree on
transgenderism you're out if you don't
agree on white guilt you're out if you
don't agree on this that or the other
thing you're out you're out you're right
if you don't agree 100 on abortion if
you don't agree on transiting the kids
on drag shows and public libraries they
they're just spiraling all of these
people who they could ordinarily attract
to their to their side
they're they're casting them all out
Bette Midler oh my gosh Bette Midler
ever since Trump was thrown off of
Twitter Bette Midler has been my
favorite Twitter account because she is
so oblivious and she's so just
regurgitates the most base level
left-wing talking points Bette Midler
just got in trouble
she got in trouble because she said
women women we're being oppressed right
she was just spouting ordinary 40 50
years ago feminist talking points but
she doesn't realize now that the left is
eating its own on feminism because of
transgenderism so she said women are
being erased they're calling us birthing
persons they're referring to chest
feeding all of the kind of transgender
language and then bet got a huge amount
of pushback
not from the right from the left
so then bet said oh gosh okay she issues
an apology she says people of the world
my tweet about women was a response to
this fascinating and well-written piece
in the New York Times on July 3rd and it
was this piece about transgenderism
racing women there was no intention of
anything exclusionary or transphobic it
was the same old s-h-i-t
uh women it's about the same same old
[ __ ] women all women have been putting
up with since the cavemen but look I've
fought for marginalized people and I've
always supported and adored them and she
goes and she's just spiraling she's
saying no no I'm a good person why are
you coming after me I'm one of the good
ones you know your talking points are a
little outdated bet that's the problem
she then tries to dig herself out of it
she posts a picture of the Supreme Court
but all the conservatives on the court
look like Muslims they've got they've
got Muslim headdress and a burqa and the
Beards on and the implication here is
that they're Theocratic or something
like that what bet doesn't realize is
the picture is very islamophobic isn't
it just like that first comment was
transphobic the second one is
islamophobic one minute she's going
after the transvestites the next minute
she goes after the Muslims why because
five ten years ago this kind of rhetoric
would have been completely ordinary you
wouldn't even think about this sort of
thing the left would have been totally
on board with it but because the
revolution constantly has to accelerate
because it's constantly it never stops
it's always perpetuating itself
eventually
it's going to contradict itself
eventually it's going to eat its own the
people who constructed the terror of the
French Revolution what happens to them
they get their heads chopped off the
revolution eats its own and poor bet who
isn't she isn't the most up-to-date
she's not
not firing on all those Pistons okay
she's she's using slightly outdated
talking points and it's enough to ruin
her reputation among her comrades
speaking of Clueless actresses
Jessica Biel posted one of my favorite
social media posts that I've seen in
days I don't know there's really good
stuff coming out these days because the
libs are so clueless they're so behind
the ball here it was a picture of
Jessica Beale with her husband Justin
Timberlake in front of the Eiffel Tower
she tweets out or posts on Instagram
you have croissants and women's rights
damn take me back
use France you see they've got women's
rights unlike America
where in America we won't let you kill
your baby
in some circumstances in America in some
states in some circumstances you're not
allowed to kill your baby
and so Jessica Beale who is completely
ignorant of pretty much everything she
posts this picture of France which is
this Beacon of liberalism it's leftism
that's where we get the term left in
politics comes from France comes from
the French Revolution and she says Ah
take me back you've got good food and
women's rights
because Jessica Biel doesn't realize
that France bans abortions after 14
weeks
France has and for a very long time has
had
much more restrictive laws on abortion
than the United States does
but Jessica Beale doesn't know that
Jessica Biel doesn't know
she doesn't know what the Dobbs decision
is actually going to mean she doesn't
know what the overruling of Roe v Wade
actually means she doesn't know what
abortion laws are around the world she
doesn't realize that America is the
outlier when it comes to abortion we're
the outlier on the pro-abortion side
the only other countries that have laws
as barbaric when it comes to abortion as
the United States does
are North Korea Canada America's hat and
China
the other countries are much much more
restrictive of of abortion
and and it's it's not even entirely
Jessica beale's fault I think a lot of
the French don't quite understand this
either I mentioned this at the very end
of the show yesterday
the French for some reason
are in France in front of the Eiffel
Tower
protesting the American Supreme Court's
decision to overrule Roe v Wade and send
the issue of abortion back to the States
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
our good fortune and it just feels
feels like a lot of solidarity here it's
very special in feels like a lot of
solidarity that's true that's the only
thing you can say about this they've got
signs they're written in French which is
saying it's a right it's the law
what law last I checked the French or
not subject to American law but and by
the way it's not even a right in your
law French and by the way the 14 weeks
is a liberalization of abortion laws
previously it had been 12 weeks or 10
weeks
what do you mean it's a right it's a law
what do you it's the solidarity this
gets to something we were talking about
yesterday too which is this idea of a
liberal world order the Biden
Administration going on TV saying stop
complaining about gas prices stop
complaining about how your economy is
falling apart we we in America we've got
to defend the liberal World Order and
you're going to have to pay for it
this is the liberal world order this is
hegemonic liberalism this is France
viewing itself not as an independent
nation but as a kind of just vassal of
the United States of the American
liberal Empire that spreads its liberal
values all around the world and so
there's a sense of solidarity
even when the the actual law the actual
constitution of these countries does not
back it up and this is a massive
acceleration these French pro-abortion
activists are not only out ahead of the
French law
they're not only contradicting their own
law
they're they're contradicting the view
of abortion everywhere in the whole even
in the whole liberal Empire even in the
United States until very very recently
back in 2015.
even back in 2015 seven years ago we
were not living in the shout your
abortion on demand without apology have
have an abortion at the 19th trimester
your your baby is going to be born in
Virginia and then you can make a
decision of whether you want to kill him
or not we weren't there in 2015. in 2015
the current president of the United
States Joe Biden then the vice president
of the United States said that abortion
is always wrong
you know there's even been the
disagreement in our church
um not that abortion is always wrong
abortion's always wrong
abortion is always wrong so says Joe
Biden the Democrat
then vice president now president of the
United States a mere seven years later
we are at abortion on demand without
apology the court has made its decision
let's see the court enforce it massive
protests in the streets not just in
America but all around the world
Biden right now is saying that of all
the things destabilizing the world
the Putin invasion of Ukraine the
American complete surrender on energy
policy the collapse of the American
Western economies Biden says the the
biggest Factor at destabilizing the
world
overruling Roe v Wade
the one thing that has been
destabilizing is the outrageous behavior
of the Supreme Court of the United
States an overruling not only Roe v Wade
but essentially challenging the right to
privacy we've been a leader in the world
in terms of personal rights and privacy
rights and it is a mistake in my view
for the Supreme Court to do what it did
the outrageous behavior of the of the
Supreme Court to restore the rule of law
and admit that the most ridiculous
decision in American history that not
even the libs defend is is not a legit
decision that's the one thing
destabilizing the world not the virus
that escaped from the laboratory in
Wuhan probably not the global lockdown
that that occurred for two years not the
a major war in Europe for the first time
since World War II not the collapse of
American Energy policy not the not the
not the not the not the no it's that the
Supreme Court is allowing the people of
the states to make their own laws with
regard to abortion that's the most
destabilizing thing so says Joe Biden
why because the United States has been a
leader on the right to privacy
well I can get right now
pull out just Google Constitution
Constitution okay U.S Constitution boom
find me the right to privacy
where do you have your Constitution
pulled up maybe you're driving don't
don't don't pull over you know you can
look it up later where is the right to
privacy in the Constitution I feel as
though I'm I'm sitting in a room with
Joe Biden by it's a padded room I'm a
doctor with a clipboard Joe Biden is
there wearing wearing some kind of
restraint or harness I say okay Mr
President this right to privacy that
you're talking about is um is that right
to privacy in the room with us now there
is no such thing as a general right to
privacy in the Constitution this was
something completely made up by the libs
they they said that it could be found
maybe between the emanations and the
penumbras and invisible inks somewhere
and one of the amendments in any way
never mind that's going to be the law
now and it never made sense and it it
really weakened our Judiciary and our
our system of government and the rule of
law in the United States and now it's
falling apart
and they did it because they thought the
ends Justified the means and they wanted
a shortcut to contraception and a
shortcut to the sexual Revolution and a
shortcut to killing babies and so they
they did that but it was always
ridiculous it was a house of cards now
it's falling apart
and now the whole thing is falling apart
and so they're all devouring their own
speaking of devouring their own I saw
one of the most disturbing stories I've
ever seen in the New York Times
the headline of it this came out just
yesterday I didn't know a few days ago
who will help care for Texas's post-row
babies
and the libs keep doing this you see it
you see it uh in in a lot of their posts
it's uh women
sometimes pregnant women holding up
little babies
and and you'll sell there's a cute
little newborn baby right there and and
the New York Times is asking this
question hey
now that Roe v Wade has been overruled
what are we going to do if we can't kill
these cute little babies and I The
Washington Post ran a story like this of
a of a young woman caring for her twin
babies who were not killed because Roe v
Wade was overruled because pro-life laws
have gone into place in the states and
they said hey what are we going to do
now and I have to think is there some
editor here who's pro-life is there some
writer's secret cabal of writers who are
pro-life here because it's if you read
the words it sounds like they're writing
pro-abortion articles but you look at
the pictures you look at the whole
subject of the story you say hold on Are
You Are you seriously advocating killing
the cute little babies devouring your
own literal children that you that you
put in these pictures is that is that
how mad your ideology has made you you
know here at the daily wire we are
celebrating the start of daily wire Plus
what is daily wire plus pretty much
everything you love from the daily wire
you get me frankly I would say that is
enough but no you get more you get Matt
you get Ben you get Drew you get Candace
plus a lot more than that we are talking
the entirety of Jordan Peterson's
existing archive podcast new shows and
bonus content plus a new series from
prageru out in the fall plus Fearless
documentaries in movies such as what is
a woman and Terror on the Prairie plus
animated kids shows of that awoke agenda
coming soon we're very excited about
Jordan's new four-part series Dragons
monsters and men streaming right now
exclusively on daily wire Plus in
Dragons monsters and men Jordan explores
what it really means to be a man and
explains how to slay the dragons in your
life and truly Excel here's a look
one of the things I tell young men well
and young women as well but the young
men really need to hear this more I
think you should be a monster an
absolute monster and then you should
learn how to control it
so a man who's capable of aggression but
has it under control is a way more
useful man than one who cannot do that
and so you're willing to go get a job
but you're terrified of an interview
it's like there's a dragon for you
because you want to fight the dragons
that guard the gates of the treasure
that you wish to attain
productivity requires aim orientation
responsibility discipline that
willingness to work that willingness to
make sacrifices which is the Hallmark of
maturity in the service of a higher goal
it orients you solidly in the world if
you do that and it gives you a dragon to
fight
what do you want to grow up you want to
be illiterate
you want to be inarticulate
you're going to have to negotiate
you're gonna have to lead you're gonna
have to convince you're gonna have to
think to say to a 18 year old
you're okay the way you are that just
deflates them
[Music]
you know when you go to the gym and you
start lifting weights well your body's
going to transform but it's not going to
do that if you just sit around you have
to face your being with the necessity of
transformation and then all sorts of new
things that you had no idea you were
capable of will make themselves manifest
those are the dragons you know the ones
that stand in the path that leads to the
light and you have to say to yourself I
will
do good
nonetheless
everyone great makes that decision
make that decision because maybe you're
great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
not only can you get Jordan Peterson on
daily wire plus but sometimes on all
access you can get me doing my Jordan
Peterson impression okay so there's a
whole lot there become a daily wire plus
member today watch Dragons monsters and
men and so much more dailywireplus.com
right now get a 35 off your new
membership dailywireplus.com we'll be
right back with a lot more
thank you
New York Times reports with pictures of
cute little babies down in Texas two
days after the Supreme Court overturned
Roe v Wade a 27 year old woman t
delivered her fourth child Cason born
after his mother fled domestic abuse and
was denied an abortion
he is among the first of many post-row
babies expected in Texas
so the the claim of the article is that
they don't know what to do with these
babies even some anti-abortion adherence
say Texas is failing families left
impoverished by its war against abortion
so we don't know what to do we can't
possibly handle the babies that the
claim is not true
it there are well when you look at
adoption for instance there are an
estimated 36 couples for every one
newborn baby put up for adoption in the
United States 36 couples looking to
adopt that baby there is no shortage of
couples looking to adopt newborn babies
now when we're talking about adoption
for older children who have been taken
out of abusive and neglectful homes and
put into the foster care system that's a
different story and it's a different
situation and you can talk all day about
the foster care system but when we're
talking about newborn babies which is
what is at issue in Roe versus Wade
there is no shortage of parents willing
to adopt there were lots of crisis
pregnancy centers the libs right now are
actually attacking and burning down this
crisis pregnancy centers but there are
still lots of them and conservatives
support them and so that the whole
premise here that there's no support
system for newborn babies that's
completely made up
but let's say it were true let's say
let's just go with it and say for the
sake of argument that it were true is
the New York Times really telling us
right now that it would be better to
kill that cute little baby Cason
she was denied an abortion she was
denied very sadly denied the right to
kill that cute little baby case and oh
it's awful now there's this new baby
born and he's probably poor and we're
gonna have more poor babies uh isn't
that the worst so terrible and
oppressive
the pro-abortion movement had one real
political Advantage for 50 years which
is that you couldn't see the victims
the victims were the most vulnerable
people that exist they were very small
they don't have a voice they can't speak
you can't even see them most of the time
and so the pro-abortion movement really
benefited from that the pro-life
movement then benefited from the Advent
of sonograms and much more sophisticated
sonogram technology now the libs are
giving away the game entirely they're
showing us a picture of the newborn baby
what are they say it'd be better to kill
this baby
friend of mine had a kind of
unconventional pro-life argument
but it's one that seems extremely
uh timely now now that the pro-abortion
side is actually showing us pictures of
the babies that they would have killed
the argument went something like this
if you're talking to someone who's
pro-abortion you say Hey you think it's
totally fine to kill the baby in the
womb the embryo the fetus the not not a
bait you don't want to call it a baby
okay the embryo you think it's totally
fine to kill the embryo yes they would
say okay okay
well then would it be totally fine if I
just went in there and we didn't kill
the embryo we just kind of poked into
its brains and kind of jiggled its
brains around
but didn't kill it the the embryo would
still grow and be born and grow up but
would just be severely severely mentally
handicapped because you went in and
scrambled up its brains
people would look at you in horror
they'd say oh my gosh no absolutely not
that would be a terrible thing to do
why would it be a terrible thing to do
well because you know you're gonna leave
the baby you're going to leave the
person severely mentally [ __ ] no you
just told me it's not a person you just
told me it's not a baby it's just a
little embryo so who cares I'm just
going to go in and scramble up his
little brains what's the problem well no
that see hold on you're telling me
you're telling me that it would be wrong
to go
give the embryo fetus baby a disability
now it would be wrong to do that but it
would not be wrong to kill him
does that make any sense to you no
of course it doesn't
because no matter how much they want to
deny it everybody knows deep down that
that thing that embryo that fetus that
zygote the Zion that's one of when a
baby is just one one cell which is it
happens for a very very brief period of
time that whatever word you want to call
it we all know that that's a person
we were all that thing at one point
and we know that it's wrong to kill that
person and I think even the New York
Times readers
they look at this article they see that
little baby and you you're really going
to tell me they're going to say ah
would that that little baby that poor
that poor black baby from rural Texas ah
we don't need any more of them do we
would that that baby were killed are you
telling me that anyone with even
a hint of a conscience we'd say that
isn't that an ugly thing to say I think
it's kind of ugly I don't I don't think
that that political movement is very
attractive we know it's not very
attractive we know it's shedding
supporters right now we know that people
are moving over in droves
to something else the Republican party
is picking up a lot of people but more
than that the Democrats are losing a lot
of people they're they're
support right now is extremely depressed
so then what do they do especially on
this issue because abortion is so in the
news with the overruling of Roe v Wade
the the Democrats have to distract on
abortion
and so they say no this isn't really
about killing your babies this isn't
about abortion this is just about
gosh women surviving miscarriage this is
an actual story it's been going viral on
the internet
healthy
Halsey who is a singer I guess
has uh an essay in Vogue in which she
says that she uh almost died
and the only thing that saved her life
was an abortion because she had multiple
miscarriages
and you see you see the problem with
that
the sentence doesn't even mean anything
I would have died from my miscarriage if
I hadn't had an abortion
you can there's a little bit of
confusion here because
in the olden days before abortion became
a political movement before killing
babies intentionally became a political
movement the term for a miscarriage was
spontaneous abortion the the pregnancy
was aborted
uh but but those two things are very
very different a miscarriage is when
naturally the baby dies in his mother's
womb a procured abortion is when people
go in and intentionally kill the baby
you cannot procure an abortion for a
miscarriage it's just it's not it's not
logically possible because a miscarriage
by definition is a baby that has already
died in the womb and so you can't abort
that baby you can only abort a living
baby but they have to blur the lines
here so no none of none of the laws none
of these pro-life laws will prevent
women from
having a miscarriage or treating a
miscarriage or anything like that
they will only prevent you from
intention like killing your baby but
they've got to blur the lines this is
why in the in the Dobbs decision in the
liberal descent
the liberal justices didn't talk very
much about Roe v Wade or Planned
Parenthood B Casey or abortion they
talked about gay marriage they talked
about contraception they talked about
homosexual sodomy in Lawrenceville Texas
they talked about all sorts of other
almost entirely unrelated issues because
they know that this issue here is so
extremely off-putting
they know that when people see the
reality of it they hate it unless
they're psychos
they knew that they had to talk about
something else the momentum is entirely
with the conservatives right now that
isn't always the case it's actually
fairly rarely the case but now we have
the momentum the libs are eating their
own they're all fighting with each other
they're on the streets of Portland
screaming and yelling and trying to out
woke each other and cast each other into
outer Darkness the conservatives are
growing the tent the conservatives are
growing the Coalition now is the time to
press forward ahead that's what's
happening in Mississippi the governor of
Mississippi Tate Reeves who's doing an
excellent excellent job down there Tate
Reeves is a building on the victory in
Dobbs to outlaw abortion pills now
abortion is outlawed in Mississippi
right now so he's going to give it some
teeth don't forget just because there
are laws on the books that doesn't
necessarily mean that the laws are going
to be enforced there are all sorts of
laws against indecent exposure and
obscenity in child endangerment and
child abuse and yet you're seeing plenty
of videos of little kids being brought
to strip club drag bars and putting
dollars in the g strings of perverts and
the laws aren't being enforced against
them so you've got to give these kinds
of laws teeth that's what governor
Reeves is doing down there in in
Mississippi he's saying if you are a
doctor and you prescribe abortion pills
you don't get to practice anymore
what does enforcement look like in your
state can a woman from Mississippi
simply travel to a different state and
have a procedure or would you try to
stop her
well in our state the enforcement is
done by the State Board of medical
licensure we have a state board of
medical licensure which actually
oversees the practice of medicine in our
state and they ensure that any physician
that is practicing whether it's through
telemedicine or otherwise that any
physician that practices in our state is
practicing not only based upon the
standards of care that we require in our
state but also based upon state law and
so if a physician is attempting to
practice medicine in the state of
Mississippi and they're violating our
law then our state board of medical
licensure will pull their license from
them
really important it's important one so
that you can enforce the pro-life laws
but two it's important to remind
conservatives
that politics is not only Downstream of
culture we've talked about this a lot
breitbart's line is very good in as much
as it means that movies matter and the
culture matters and the way people live
outside of the law and the formal
political order and the government
matter
but it's a slogan and like all slogans
it's wrong
because
politics affects culture as well
politics is a is a teacher the law is a
teacher we know this from the Bible we
know this from political philosophy we
know this from practice
laws help shape the culture too
if you
Outlaw abortion in Mississippi but you
don't have any consequences for doctors
who continue to practice abortion
you're still going to get a lot of
abortion
if on the other hand you say hey if you
in any way participate in abortion
you're going to lose your medical
license you're not going to be able to
practice here maybe you can go to
another state I don't know maybe you
can't
but all that schooling all that money
that you dumped into your career the way
that you put food on your table and pay
your bills yeah that all goes away
if you break this law then I think
you're going to see something a little
bit different you saw this on the flip
side during covet and it was very
unfortunate during covid but during
covet there were a lot of people who
wanted to
avoid some of the vaccine mandates
because they suspected correctly that
the covid shots were not going to do
exactly what Biden and wolensky in fact
she told us they were going to do
prevent transmission prevent infection
they were a little skeptical
that the covid shots were 100 totally
safe and effective no side effects no
risk whatsoever they were skeptical they
wanted to get around it and they would
go to doctors and they'd find
sympathetic doctors
and they'd go to the doctor and say hey
Doc I just need a card shoot the shot
down the sink whatever just whatever you
got to do I don't want to get this shot
but I have to keep my job and even the
doctors who say I I spoke to doctors I
spoke to Pharmacists and doctors who
said I don't think you should take this
shot I don't think not not only young
people I don't think most people should
take this shot it's really it hasn't
been tested there are no long-term data
here the risk from covet is not
particularly great for most people I
really don't think you should do it then
you say okay good give me a fake card
and they'd say no can't do it I could
lose my license
I could lose my license and I can't take
that risk
the law is a teacher sometimes it can be
a teacher for bad ends like you saw
during covid in this case it can be a
teacher for very good ends
regardless the culture can in fact be
Downstream of politics a great job to
Governor Reeves
some conservatives pushing ahead some
conservatives totally squishing if you
look across the pond at our limey
cousins over there in the United Kingdom
Boris Johnson is making the argument now
that the cause of the Russian invasion
of Ukraine is toxic masculinity
you need more women in positions of
power if Putin was a woman
which he obviously isn't but if he were
I really don't think he would have
embarked on a crazy Macho war of in
great of invasion and violence in the
way that he has if you want a perfect
example of toxic masculinity it's it
would it's what he's doing in in Ukraine
toxic is toxic masculinity I'm Boris
Johnson the conservative it's I don't
even mean to beat up that much on Boris
Johnson he has been something of a
disappointment as a conservative PM I
think the right Wingers were hoping for
a lot more from Boris and he's kind of
squished on some pretty big issues
he's even using the language of the left
I mention it not to knock on Johnson so
much as to point out that liberalism is
hegemonic
liberalism is the air that we breathe
liberalism is the the environment that
we all move in and even we conservatives
even the rock ribbed people we will use
the language of liberalism
that's how powerful it is that's how
thorough the revolution has been I wrote
my book last year speechless controlling
risk controlling Minds which became a
number one National bestseller thanks to
you hey we still have the Bell that's
great I wrote the book on this topic
it's so much worse than just the left
uses their crazy language and then we
don't no we use it too they've they've
the left has managed to in in many ways
win the big political debates before
they even have the debate because they
infect our minds with their language and
language is what constitutes our
Consciousness in many ways and so we
just see the world through their lenses
Boris Johnson the conservative is seeing
the world through a leftist lens of
toxic masculinity and if only the world
were run by women then we'd have peace
and Harmony can you imagine I don't know
what about that lady on the street in
Portland I'm not sure she would give us
peace and Harmony I don't think the man
necessarily would either
that that is the kind of Revolution we
are up against and you are seeing like
revolutions that are totalizing you were
seeing the real the real overstepping
the devouring of their own children
happening right now this is an
opportunity you've got to take this
opportunity you've got politics like
comedy is about timing okay you've got
to know your timing we're in a a real
moment of opportunity right now we have
to take it
speaking of killers we're talking about
Vladimir Putin speaking of killers
closer to home
the Highland Park killer
we're now learning a little bit more
about him uh we don't we don't say his
name we don't say the names of these
Mass killers on the network because we
don't want to give them notoriety people
are all quibbling over is he a right
winger or a left Winger
I've gone down the rabbit hole looking
at Arguments for both it seems to me he
probably wasn't particularly partisan or
political at all
he showed up to Trump rallies but some
people said it was ironic and then he
posted lots of anti-conservative things
on social media but then he also wore
the Pepe the frog symbol and he didn't
and it just
for the vast majority of killers in
history they don't have a
of at least of these kind of mass serial
killer you know mass shooting types in
America they don't have a strong
political agenda they're just whack
sometimes people can just be wackos okay
sometimes people can just be lunatics
and I think that's the case here with
with this kid he doesn't he certainly
doesn't look like a conservative he
looks much more like a leftist but he
doesn't even seem to have that much
strong of a leftist political argument
well now what we know about him is
in 2019 the police were told that this
Shooter had vowed to kill everyone
he had tried to kill himself then he
said he was going to kill everyone the
cops took a bunch of weapons away from
him but but didn't arrest him and didn't
really do very much and everyone knew
this kid was a ticking time bomb and he
just looked like a nut and he was
posting all sorts of crazy scary stuff
on social media and nobody did anything
about it
there's going to be a lot of finger
pointing everywhere and it should have
been the parents and it should have been
the cops should have been the school and
it should have been this and it should
have been that
I do think there is something we could
do that would reduce the likelihood of
these wackos with lots and lots of
warning signs popping off and killing
people and I think the thing we need to
do is
re-stigmatize craziness
we all talk these days but how we need
to reduce stigmas especially around
mental health we need to reduce the
stigma around mental health and we need
to take away shame and feelings of guilt
we just need to normalize everything
okay and every and if you have some
bizarre fantasies or delusions or you
just we need to
we need to make it all seem normal no we
don't
we really shouldn't
we the only way in which we should
destigmatize mental health problems is
such that people go seek treatment
otherwise we need to re-stigmatize it is
it is not good to be crazy craziness
these days confers a kind of social
currency if you can claim to have some
sort of mental illness you can claim a
sort of privilege in the intersectional
hierarchy of society and this is
especially true when it comes to sexual
dysphoria this is especially true if you
say look I'm I'm a man but I think that
I'm a woman that gives you a great deal
of privilege in our society it shouldn't
if you're a man and you think that
you're a woman and it's not you're not
just taking part in a social Mania but
you actually have some psychological
condition you should go seek help for
that and the doctor should not affirm
you in your delusion the doctor should
tell you about reality and convince you
actually you know you're you're a man
you're not really a woman you're a man
and if you have such psychiatric
problems that you are a danger to
yourself or to society you should be
locked up we closed the mental asylums
in the United States we wanted to
destigmatize mental health problems that
hasn't turned out very well just look
around the Streets of San Francisco or
New York or DC I'm not just talking
about the drug addicts and the criminals
I'm talking about the crazy people there
are lots of crazy people living on the
streets and we all pretend that it's
really compassionate to let crazy people
live in squalor and filth and danger on
the streets and then die of exposure
during the winter it's not compassionate
at all we need to make it much much more
stigmatized to be crazy so that people
can go seek treatment and live better
lives part of the reason for this part
of the reason we closed down the asylums
and part of the reason that people
tolerate this kind of stuff today
letting the crazy people continue to be
a danger to themselves into society is
because of a peculiar ideology that
affects both the left and the right
which is the ideology of individualism
we don't want to tell anybody what to do
well who am I to say who am I even to
say that you're crazy
maybe the man who thinks that he's a
woman maybe he is the same one maybe I'm
the crazy one for thinking that I'm a
man maybe the person who hears voices in
his heads maybe he's the same one I
don't know who's to say what how do I I
don't want to impose My Views
of uh culture or politics or religion or
or
psychology or human nature onto anybody
else but but of course we have to that's
what Society is society is coming
together and agreeing on some basic
things and living together
that's what laws are the law and the law
is a teacher and the law will will not
just uh be a product of how people are
living
but the law will shape how people live
as well
this we've known this going all the way
back to those old ancient Greeks okay
and and we need to do that here as well
because if we continue to let people
languish and and spiral and go into
their own craziness and their own
delusions that will cause a great deal
of harm for them and for everybody else
you want to talk about craziness I have
to get to this story
Jordan Peterson
my new colleague Jordan Peterson and
Dave Rubin
have been booted off of Twitter
for saying that a a woman is a woman
Jordan set this all off he tweeted out
remember when Pride was a sin and Ellen
Page just had her breasts removed by a
criminal physician so he tweeted that
and he got booted because he said Ellen
Page and even though that's the
actress's name
you're not allowed to say her name
anymore because she says that she's
Elliot now and she says that she's not a
she and she is a he but of course she is
actually a she and and she's not Elliot
either some conservatives try to split
the baby on this issue and they say look
I won't use the crazy pronouns but I
will call her by whatever name she wants
because you can legally change your name
and so I'll call you whatever you want
no I don't think so I think that's a
little too clever by half Elliott is a
boy name Ellen is a girl name Ellen is a
girl and Ellen is Ellen so that's the
point that Jordan made and Jordan got
booted from Twitter for it for dead
naming meaning calling her by her
correct name and using the right
pronouns then Dave just tweeted out a
picture of it he said the insanity
continues at Twitter uh Jordan was just
suspended for this tweet about Ellen
Page and then then Dave was kicked off
Twitter for posting the Tweet by Jordan
this rule on Twitter is effectively a
Banning of of disagreement with
transgenderism if you are not allowed to
call the Girl by the girl's name if you
were forced to call the Girl by the
boy's name and if you were not allowed
to call the girl
she or her girl pronouns and you have to
call the girl he or him boy pronouns
then Twitter has effectively banned
opposition to transgenderism and Twitter
is a major part of our Public Square so
Twitter acting as a sort of enforcement
arm of the liberal government
has said you are not allowed to disagree
with transgenderism in public it is not
enough just to lift these bands it is
not enough if we ever get power again in
these institutions if Elon buys Twitter
or something it is not enough just to
lift the bands we have to punish the
people who do this they are they are
perverting our political order they are
acting in a way that is extremely unjust
and harmful to the country very
destructive
we need to punish the sensors for doing
this sort sort of thing we need to fire
them ideally we would ostracize them
okay we need to we need to stop this
it's very very destructive the people
are on our side on this issue Bette
Midler is on our side on this issue they
see gray is on our side on this issue
not exactly Rock ribbed conservatives we
have the wind at our sails stand up say
the truth stop squishing push forward
ahead timing is almost everything here
and we've gotta we've got a narrow
window where we can get some serious
victories push ahead I'm Michael Knowles
that's the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
the Michael Knowles show is produced by
Ben Davies executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover production manager Pavel vidovsky
editor and Associate producer Danny
D'Amico associate producer Justine
Turley audio mixer Mike coromina and
hair and makeup by Cherokee heart
Michael Knoll show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
today on the Ben Shapiro show while
Democrats push gun control and red flag
loss we find out all about the red flag
surrounding the latest Mass shooter Joe
Biden's approval rating continues to
tank and Dave Rubin is suspended from
Twitter for noticing the Jordan Peterson
was suspended from Twitter so it's
Twitter ban infinite regress time that's
today on the Ben Shapiro show give it a
listen